former Trump campaign chairman Paul
Manafort and his associate Rick Gates
are the first to face charges in the
Russia election probe and there may be
others soon both men pleaded not guilty
yesterday to a dozen charges
they include conspiracy against the
United States money laundering and tax
fraud
we also learned yesterday that George
papadopolis a foreign policy adviser to
the Trump campaign pleaded guilty to
other charges he admits he lied to the
FBI about his contacts with Russian
interests the 30 year old had no prior
criminal record Papadopoulos was
arrested July 27th at Washington Dulles
International Airport his case was under
seal for the last three months while
Special Counsel Robert Miller
investigated possible Trump campaign
links to Russia the government calls
Papadopoulos quote a proactive
cooperator deprecates is in Washington
with a look at what that means and where
this investigation is heading Jeff good
morning good morning that term indicates
that George papadopolis may now be
actively working with a special counsels
office to reveal who and the Trump
campaign knew that he was communicating
with Russian operatives and when
Papadopoulos is arrest and guilty plea
was a bombshell yesterday showing that
he too was offered damaging information
on Hillary Clinton by Russian operatives
so help me God
two days after president Trump's
inaugurations George papadopolis was in
Israel and appeared to still be acting
on behalf of the campaign a new
relationship between the United States
according to court documents less than a
year earlier Papadopoulos began emailing
Trump campaign officials and pushing
meetings with Russian operatives at a
national security meeting on March 31st
2016 Papadopoulos told mr. Trump that he
had connections that could help arrange
a meeting between then candidate Trump
and President Putin 10 days earlier mr.
Trump introduced his newly minted
foreign policy team to editors from the
Washington Post George papadopolis but
on Monday night mr. Trump's lawyer told
CBS News that the president definitely
doesn't have a clue who george
papadapolis is Papadopoulos is
communication with the Russian
operatives began when the main contact
nicknamed the professor told him in
April of 2016 that he had dirt on then
candidate Hillary Clinton including
thousands of emails that occurred well
before the Democratic National Committee
made the intrusion by Russian hackers
public in May 2016 Papadopoulos emailed
a high-ranking campaign official Russia
has been eager to meet mr. Trump that
email was forwarded with this commentary
Donald Trump is not doing these trips it
should be someone low level in the
campaign so as not to send any signal in
August after mr. Trump accepted the
Republican nomination for president a
campaign supervisor encouraged
Papadopoulos to make the trip to Russia
if it is feasible another former trump
foreign policy advisor Carter Paige did
make a trip to Russia where he gave a
speech in July of 2016 age was asked
last night whether he had exchanged
emails with Papadopoulos probably a few
yeah were you an email chains with him
about Russia it may have come up from
time to time
Carter Paige and several other Trump
campaign officials have been under FBI
scrutiny for more than a year now
Papadopoulos is facing up to five years
in prison but he won't be sentenced
until the Muller investigation is over
Norah
all right Jeff thank you so much